elle encourt le handicap est au coeur
d'une semaine spéciale jusqu'au 22 avril
la ville souhaite à travers cette
semaine changer le regard que portent
ses habitants sur le handicap grâce à
divers animations est temps forts l'un
d'eux s'étant avait lieu cet après midi
avec un atelier de pâtisserie adapté à
l'agora patrick jacques de dixmude et
mélanie poker on vit depuis dix ans non
rudin se lance dans la préparation d'un
mendiant une pâtisserie au chocolat ils
participent à un atelier culinaire pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
ouais vraiment parce que j'aime bien
dans le pathos rails c'est là que la
cousine la pâtisserie et m'ont donné des
chocolats j'ai lu j'élis fondu dans le
micro-ondes et après comme j'ai dû
sortir les micro ondes
j'ai les races et qu'ils se soient bien
vendu et après et nous ont donné un
maître dans la recette classique et mon
milieu trou et après j'ai commencé
à mettre dans les ports les papiers une
recette simple des explications courte
l'animation est faite par l'association
élan courtoise la toque au coeur je suis
concernée par le handicap par mama fier
en fait était en fauteuil roulant et
donc c'est une activité qu'on pratique
souvent à la maison donc doux d'où
l'idée en fait de créer une association
pour ce à partir avec sa création et
puis c'est vrai que je crée aussi une
petite fiche recette
donc ils vont qui leur permet de pouvoir
refaire à la maison avec les petites
techniques que j'ai donné pendant cours
douze apprentis pâtissiers se sont
essayés à la cuisine du chocolat depuis
mardi à elancourt c'est la semaine du
handicap
d'autres animations sont prévues jusqu'à
samedi